[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان
تتفاعل واخرى هذه اللقطات من العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه التي تستعد لاخر مواجهتين
في كاس العالم لكره القدم مونديال قطر
2022 غدا وبعد غد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
دفاعيه جديده
لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
عن التفاهمات الثنائيه
مع طوكيو
في مواصفات بالضربات الاكبر والاعنف منذ
بدء الحرب قسم صاروخين روسي مكثف على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ومدن اخرى يقول ان
الهجمه لن تغير ميزان القوه في الحرب
وسلطات المواليه
باستهداف مواقع مدنيه
على موعد مع انتخابات تشريعيه جديده وسط
مقاطعه اغلب الاحزاب الرئيسيه والهيئه
العليا للانتخابات تؤكد للجزيره انها بمن
ان عن اي تجاذبات سياسيه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم تهديدا المفوضيه
الاوروبيه لمالك منصه تويتر الى الماسك
بفرض عقوبات بعد تعليقه لحسابات تابعه
لصحفيين على هذه المنصه حيث كانت قد اوقفت
اي منصه حسابات لصحفينا التوام باء عن
مالك منصه بعد ايام من حضر حسابات حساب
بالاحرى يتتبعوا مكان وجود طائرته الخاصه
مما ادى الى ردود فعل عنيفه وسط سياسينا
اوروبيه
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي الذي يقول هل سيثبت
تلويح الاوروبي بالعقبات ماسك عن اجراءاته
المتعلقه بحضر الحسابات
29% قالوا نعم ان التلويح بالعقوبات
سيثنيه عن ذلك فيما جابت 49% بلا بينما
قال اثنين وعشرون بالمائه انه ماسك قد
يتراجع لكن جزئيا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقاءنا على الملصقات الرقم
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
بريطانيا على موعد مع المزيد من الاضرابات
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال التي ترصد مستجدات كاس
العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
البدايه من اليابان حيث اعلنت الحكومه
هناك استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده
وصفت خلالها وصفات خلالها الصين بانها
تحدن استراتيجي غير مسبوق لامنها القومي
للامن القومي
من القوانين في ما وصف باكبر مراجعه
لسياسه البلاد الدفاعيه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه حيث تتضمنت مضاعفه وزاره
الدفاع السنويه او الدفاع بشكل عام الى
اكثر من 50 مليار دولار اي اثنين بالمئه
من الناتج المحليه في غضون خمس سنوات ما
يجعل الميزانيه العسكريه اليابانيه
الثالثه في العالم بعد الولايات المتحده
والصين
في صلاحيه قتال جديده وميزانيه عسكريه
مضاعفه تفتح اليابان صفحه جديده في تاريخ
قواتها العسكريه
فبعد التعديل الذي اقرته الحكومه على ما
تعرف بالوثائق الثلاث
للاستراتيجيه الامنيه والدفاعيه اصبحت هذه
القوات تمتلك لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
صلاحيه شنها جمال ضد دوله معاديه
لكن رئيس الوزراء كيشيدي يشدد على ان مثل
تلك الضربات المضاده ستقتصر على الدفاع عن
النفس ولن تكون السباقيه ابدا
هذا العام لاول مره منذ خمسه اعوام اطلقت
كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليستيا مره فوق
اليابان وسقطت صواريخها في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لبلادنا هي تحضر
لتجربه نوويه تدفعون تلك التهديدات
الواقعيه لاجراء تعديل تاريخي على سياستنا
الدفاعيه
[موسيقى]
الدفاعيه الجديده سيتم مضاعفه الانفاق
العسكري خلال السنوات القادمه
الثالثه بين اكبر الميزانيات العسكريه بعد
الولايات المتحده والصين والتي اصبحت وفقا
للتعديلات الجديده التحدي الاستراتيجيه
الاكبر لليابان اما روسيا فهي تمثل الى
جانب كوريا الشماليه تهديدا محتمالا
وقويتي وقاعدين اثار غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
قلق اليابان فقد اثبت ان وقوع مثل هذا
الغزو امر ممكن وعلى اليابان ان تتحضر لاي
سيناري ومحتمل من خلال تعزيز قوتها
العسكريه وقدرتها على الرادار
على تعزيز قوه خفر السواحل لحمايه الجزر
اليابانيه النائيه في اشاره الى جزر
تسميها اليابان سينكو وتتنازعوا على
السياده عليها مع الصين ستراس اليابان في
العام القادم مجموعه السبع وستحصل على
مقعدين غير دائم في مجلس الامن الدولي وهو
من شانه
الاضواء على السياسات الخارجيه لليابان في
ظل قوانين الدفاعها الجديده فادي سلامه
الجزيره طوكيو
وتتضمن السياسه الدفاعيه الجديده لليابان
تغييرات جذريه في العقيده الامنيه التي
ضلت تحكم البلاد بعقود منذ هزيمتها في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وتكشف التهديدات
الامنيه التي تضمنت هذه السياسه المتعلقه
بروسيا والصين وكوريا الجنوبيه تكشف مدى
التنسيق بين طوكيو واشنطن في مواجهه
القضايا الجيوستراتيجيه المنحه في اقصى
شرق الكره الارضيه
في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه وجدت
اليابان نفسها مرغمه على القبول
الولايات المتحده تنبذ الفقره التاسعه منه
الحربكه وسيله لتسويه النزاعات لذا منعت
اليابان من تشكيل الجيش واسست بدلا منه ما
سميت بقوه الدفاع الذاتي لكنها ممنوعه من
ارسال قوه الى الخارج ومن المشاركه في
ترتيبات الامن والدفاع الجماعي بناء على
ذلك تبنت اليابان ودمنه سياستها الدفاعيه
ثلاثه مبادئ تحضر عليها تصنيع او امتلاك
اسلحه نوويه كما تحضر صادرات الاسلحه
والمعدات الدفاعيه وثالث هذه المبادئ هو
الحد من انفاقها الدفاعي حيث لا يتجاوز
واحده في المئه من الناتجه المحلي سنويا
اما الان فالمراجعه الجديده للسياسه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه توصف بالاكبر منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وتمثل تحطيما
للقيود التي ضلت تقرها القوانين اليابانيه
رغم التعديلات الطفيفه في خلال العقود
الماضيه فسقف الانفاق العسكري سيرتفع الى
الضعف لتصير الميزانيه الدفاعيه السنويه
للبلاد من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بحلول
عام 2027
وتصبح بذلك اليابان صاحبه الثالث اكبر
ميزانيه عسكريه في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده والصين بينما ستودع قوات الدفاع
الذاتي البريه والبحريه والجويه ذات
الصلاحيه المحدوده تحت قياده موحده في
غضون خمس سنوات
تقضي السياسه الدفاعيه الجديده بامتلاك
قدره على شان هجوم مضاد باسلحه يمكن ان
تستهدف مواقع اطلاق ثواريخ العدو وباتت
الصين وروسيا وكوريا الشماليه مصدر قلق
كبير وتهديد لليابان مع اعتبار الصين اكبر
تحدي اسيراتيجيا لسلام اليابان واستقرارها
التوجه الجديد لقي ثناءا امريكيه فقد قال
وزير الخارجيه
اليابان تتلاقى مع الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
وتعيد قدره التحالف بين البلدين على حمايه
النظام القائم على القواعد في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادي
وفي رد الفعل الصيني حثت بجين اليابان على
التفكير في سياستها وقال المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه وان وان تركي
تتجاهل الحقائق وتحيد عن التفاهمات
المشتركه بين الصين واليابان والتزامها
بالعلاقات الثنائيه
بدعم السلام والاستقرار في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وخارجها الصين فرصه وشارك
كل جميع البلدان التي تسعى الى التنميه
تتجاهل اليابان الحقائق وتبتعد عن
التفاهمات المشتركه بينها وبين الصين
والتزامها بالعلاقات الثنائيه وتشوه سمعه
الصين نحن نعرض ذلك بشده وقد قدمنا عريضه
لتوضيح موقف الرسمي من خلال القنوات
الدبلوماسيه
وقد رحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطه
الدفاعيه الجديده التي اقرتها طوكيو وقال
البيت الابيض ان الخطه الدفاعيه الجديده
لليابان تهدف الى تعزيز التحالف العسكري
مع الولايات المتحده واعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جوبيدو ان بلاده تقف الى جانب
اليابان في هذه اللحظه الحرجه مؤكدا ان
التحالف الامريكيه الياباني اساسي في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهاديل
معنى الان من لندن زنك استاذ الدراسات
الصينيه والدوليه في جماعه لانجستر اهلا
وسهلا بك
ما الذي سيتغير الان في ضوء هذه
الاستراتيجيه اليابانيه الدفاعيه الجديده
عاوز سكس
يكون
في طريقه الدفع
بعد الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
العالميين ولهذا راينا اذا تغيرا فكره
الدفاعيه هناك شعور
بان هناك تهديد حرب
ومعارك ولهذا قررت اليابان اعتماد
الاستراتيجيه الجديده
مع الصين مع روسيا وطبعا كوريا الشماليه
وهي قديمه
بالنسبه الى كوريا الشماليه اعتقد ان
المساله لم تعد ترتبط بصوره اساسيه في همم
تغير النوع العدو او هويته ولكن هناك
احتمال الوقوع نزاع عسكريه هذا هو التغيير
الرئيسي كذلك
اعتقد ان هذا تغيير رمزيلي وقع ذلك على
المجتمع حيث ان هناك
ترويج لضروره ان يؤخذ احتمال حصول هذه
تعديدات على محمل الجاد هذا لم ياخذ ليكن
ياخذ على محمل الجد من قبل ولكن الان
الناس والمجتمع ساخذه على محمل الجاد
وطبعا سيكونوا اكثر استعدادا لتقبل زياده
الميزانيه الدفاعيه هل نتوقع توتر متزايدا
بين الصين واليابان لان الصين تلقت الخبر
بكثير من القلق
نور
ليست سعيده
[موسيقى]
ولا تتفهم ان اليابان مهتمه بالموضوع
لماذا تكون اليابان مهتمه بها
كذلك
العلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه بين
اليابان والصين علاقات
واسعه النطاق هذا
تحديا دبلوماسيه طبعا سيكون له تبيعات او
سيكون لها تابعاتها هذا ليس امرا جديدا
دائما كان هناك نوع من التوازن بين
العلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه من جهه
وتوتورات الامنيه ولكن قد هي تايوان قديه
اساسيه وا اسفين تعتبره وقضيه داخليه لا
شئنا لليابان بها
وهمم طبعا سوف لن تتقبل ان تقارن هذه
القضيه بقضيه اوكرانيا
لا تتدخل في الشؤون السياسيه اليابانيه
بينما قد تايوانيه والدوليه
هذا النقاش ستكون له مساحه اضافيه في فقره
في المتابعه بعد قليل حيث سنسال اكثر ولكن
عن تطورات هذه العقيده العسكريه اليابانيه
الجديده وانعكاسات القرار على الصعيد
الداخلي
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا لان حيث تجدد القصف ولكن هذه
المره هو قصف هو الاكبر منذ بدايه الحرب
هكذا وصفت السلطات الاوكرانيه الهجمات
الصاروخيه التي تعرضت لها كيف ومدن اخرى
اليوم
وكانت الضربات قد استهدفت بالاساس البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه يحدث هذا في وقت لا يخفى
فيه او لا يخفي فيه عفوا الجيش الاوكراني
مخاوفه من ان تشن موسكو هجوما جديدا على
ثياب الاشهر الاولى من العام المقبل وفي
خلفيه هذه التطورات يتواصل والسيال خطته
واشنطن لارسال منظومه للدفاع الجوي الى
اوكرانيا
تتعرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه لاحدى اوسع
الهجمات الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب
الجويه اسقطت 37 صاروخا من اصل 40 استهدفت
العاصمه لم تكن كيف وحيده اليوم تحت القصف
الروسي ثاني اكبر المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
واسعه النطاق اكثر من 60 صاروخ روسيا
اطلقت اليوم على اوكرانيا اهداف القوات
الروسيه تتركز على البنيه التحتيه ومنشات
الطاقه بشكل اساسي بينما يدق الشتاء
ابوابات تلك المناطق البارده اصلا تتضرر
بقصف اليوم 9 منشات للطاقه الاوكرانيه
يكون لهذه الضربات اهداف على المدى
المتوسط والبعيد تريد موسكو ان يكون شتاء
ثقيلا على الاوكرانيين هكذا تركيه في
الامر
تحولت محطه القطار الى ملاجئ مؤقته وحل
الظلام في معظم المدن الاوكرانيه
اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه العمل بنظام
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي الطارئ في جميع
انحاء البلاد بسبب استهداف منشات الطاقه
رغم كل ذلك تقول القوات الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعتها الجويه تصدت لمعظم الصواريخ
الروسيه هنا يتصدر المشهد مطالباتك ايفل
الغرب في المزيد من منظومات الدفاع الجوي
لصد الهجمات الروسيه
باتريوت كلمه السر التي تبحث عنها كياب من
واشنطن بامكان هذه المنظومه ان تغير في
المعادله وان تمنح الاوكرانيا تفوقا
يمنحهم شتاء اقل بردا توجد منظومه باتريوت
التي تعمل على تامين المجال الجوي لدول
الناتو في اوروبا الشرقيه في رومانيا
وبولندا وكذلك في دول اوروبيه اخرى
كالمانيا وهولندا واسبانيا وضعت واشنطن
لمسات الاخيره على تزويديه
من التفاصيل الفنيه
او اي من المستشارين او المدربين الغربيين
المتوقع وصولهم الى اوكرانيا لتدريب الجيش
هنا هكذا تقترب الحرب من طي شهرها العاشر
تزداد توتر مع تاثيرات اوكرانيه من هجوم
روسيا واسع النطاق قبل ان يغلق الشتاء
الطرق المؤديه لاي حسب عسكري في الميدان
اما في تطورات المعارك على الارض باقليم
دمشقيه اوكرانيا فقد اعلنت سلطات المواليه
لروسيا في مقاطعه لوغانس مقتل 13 شخص جراء
قصف اوكراني بصواريخ هي مارس وبا المدفعيه
استهدف مبانيه سكنيه اما في دنياز فقالت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان حصيله قتل
القذف الاوكراني ارتفع الى ثلاثه اشخاص
معنا من نيويورك العقيده
الباحث في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه
الامريكيه والمتحدث السابق باسم قوات
التحالف الدوليه في العراق وسوريا ومن
موسكو فيكتور لطفيين الخبير العسكري
والعقيد الاحتياط في الجيش الروسيه اهلا
بضيفين نبدا من نيويورك عقيده همم الان
همم موسكو تهدد ان اي معدات او مدربين همم
ستقدمهم الولايات المتحده سيقع استهدافهم
هل نتوقع تطور نوعي في سير المعارك في
اوكرانيا
مساء الخير مساء الخير
لتدافع عن نفسها من اجتياح روسيا لها
اليوم
التزم
الامريكي
مئات الملايين من الدولارات الاضافيه من
اجل تصنيع الاسلحه
والذخائر من اجل توفيرها الى اوكرانيا
للدفاع عن نفسها حاليا ليس هناك اي اعلان
عن اي وجود
مستشارين او مدربين امريكيين يدخلون
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا
ممتازا في دفاعا عن نفسها من الاعتداءات
الروسيه
ترسل واشنطن بالضروره مدربين ومستشارين
لان المساله ليست بسيطه
ولد فارس
في السبب الذي يدعو الى حصول نقاشات حول
ارسال منظومه الى اوكرانيا فاليوم راينا
ان الجيش الروسي قد اطلق اكثر من 70
صاروخا موجه عند مواقع
المدنيه في الاراضي الاكرانيه نتحدث هنا
عن مواقع في مدن في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا حيث
تحاور روسيا ان تدمر
ازواج الطاقه في اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى
اعتداءات على مرافقات طبيه
وبسبب هذه الاعتداءات الروسيه
على اوكرانيا ان تدرس كافه السبل والوسائل
لتحفي عن نفسها من اعتداءات بالصواريخ
البالستيه وغيرها من الصواريخ البعيده
المد التي تطلقها روسيا
هل هذا سيستمر فقط في ضوء استمرار
الامدادات الغربيه مرهون بذلك
في الحقيقه ان الايراد الاوكرانيه للقتال
هذا العزم هذه القوه في اراده
ومعنوياته الجيش والشعب الاوكراني كانت
كلها عوامل
شكلت هذا النجاح ولكن طبعا
من الولايات المتحده ومن الدول
الاعضاء
حدثت هذا الفرق لصالح اوكرانيا حتى تتمتع
بالقدرات التكتيكيه للتصدي للقوات الروسيه
واخراجها من شرقي وشمالي اوكرانيا
من الغرب سوف يستمر في مساعدتي اوكرانيا
و 23 سيد لتوفقين في في موسكو في ضوء هذا
الكلام هل تتوقع همم
امكانيه تصادم امريكي روسي ربما في الفتره
المقبله هذا الخطر قائم في اوكرانيا
هذا النوع من التصادم لان امريكا لا تريد
حرب مباشر مع
روسيا الفيدراليه التي لديها قدرت نوويه
عظيمه من الصواريخ ولكن الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه التي ضربت بولندا واول من قال
انه كان صاروخا اوكرانيا كان الرئيس
بولنديون وكان يعني انه صاروخ روسي
لا يريد تصادم مباشر بين الولايات المتحده
بشكل سيء
الدوله الاولى والثانيه اما هناك شيء اخر
ان بالنسبه لامريكا من النافع ان تحارب
روسيا عن طريق اوكرانيا ان تحارب امريكا
الروسيه عن طريق اوكرانيا
الامريكي سوف يزيد غناء بسبب هذه الحرب
القصف اليوم سيد همم لتبكين القصف على كيف
وعلى مدن اوكرانيه اخرى وصف بانه الاعنف
والاكبر منذ بدايه الحرب ما الذي حصل حتى
يصبح كذلك
بالامس
نظام
المنشات والمواطنين كان هناك همم ضربات
بالصواريخ جراند لذلك روسيا تستمر
الطاقه في اوكرانيا وتدمير محطات القطارات
التي تنقل الاسلحه والذخيره من الدول
الغربيه الى الجبهات وهذه احداث للمعارك
الطبيعيه جدا استهدف البنيه التحتيه الذي
اثرت اليه قطعه الكهرباء عن مناطق عديده
همم هذه السياسه بالنسبه لروسيا هل هي ذات
جدوى
بالطبع انهم لا يتمكنون من التحكم مع
بالعمليات العسكريه وتدمر المراكز
العسكريه ومراكز الاداره
وشبكات التواصل
لذلك عندما تقل قدراتهم بالرادارات
والتواصل على الجبهات عندهم عندها لن
يستطيعوه من التواصل مع المراكز العسكريه
فهذا هو تاثير كبير وهذا يؤدي الى نجاح
القوه الروسيه يعني مع همم دخول فصل
الشتاء وهو يبدو انه سيكون قاسيا هل تتوقع
اي تغيير في سير المعارك في اوكرانيا
انه سوف يكون هناك تغييرات بالطبع لان
القوات الروسيه حصلت على مدمن الجنود
والجنود الذين تم تدريبهم وتعبيرهم وصلوا
الى الجبهات وهناك اسلحه جديده ايضا وهذا
سوف يمنح الفرصه للقوات
الروسيه ان تصل الى
هجمات
الذي كان معنا من نيويورك العقيده
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث تستعد البلاد الانطلاق عمليه
الاقتراع في الانتخابات البرلمانيه في
الداخل في اثناء يوصل الناخبون التونسيون
في المهجر الادلاء باصواتهم في الانتخابات
التشريعيه وقد اعلنت هيئه الانتخابات ان
الانتخابات في المهجر سجلت اقبالا ضعيفا
في يومها الاول وقد قرر البرلمان الاوروبي
عدم ارسال بعثه لمراقبه الانتخابات
التونسيه كما ذهب مدعم 2000 واحد عشره
وقال ان قراره مبني على قرار المحكمه
الافريقيه لحقوق الانسان وتقرير لجنه
البندقيه بالاضافه الى التطورات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في البلاد
وبلشان ما يوجهه لهيئه الانتخابات
التونسيه من اتهامات بعدم الحياد قال
الناطق الرسمي باسم الهيئه التليي للمنصري
الجزيره ان الهيئه بمن انا عن التجاذبات
السياسيه
فاحنا دي ما نحبه عن هاته التجاذبات اولا
وثانيا بالنسبه لعمل الهيئه في الواقع نحن
نعمل تحت ضمانات تحت ضمنات اولا رقابه
المجتمع المدني رقابه الصحافه رقابه
الاعلام رقابه الملاحظين الدوليين
والمحليين نحن تقريبا هناك اربع ما يتجاوز
العرب 480 ملاحظ محلي وتقريبا 830 ملاحظه
دولي واكثر من 200 تقريبا صحافه اجنبيه
دوليه همم قدمنا كل الاعتمادات لكل من
يطلب ومن يريد الملاحظه الا من يرفض
التعامل مع الهيئه هذا حقه في نهايه
المطاف المقاطعه وفي نهايه المطاف كذلك
موقف نخدم كذلك ونعمل تحت رقابه محكمه
اداريه
واضاف الناطق باسم الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس ان الهيئه كانت تتمنى
مشاركه المراقبين دوليين قائلا ان قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي عدم ارسال مراقبين
للانتخابات البرلمانيه لن يغير من
استراتيجيه الهيئه في اسناد الاعتماد لمن
يرغب من المراقبين وفق الشروط القانونيه
معناها ملاحظين من جميع الدول العالم حتى
من الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه تعودنا انهم
يقوموا بالملاحظات همم لانه الهيئه
الاستراتيجيه يمتحها لن تتغير كل من يطلب
اعتماد ويريد الملاحظه فنحن نمكنه من ذلك
تبقى شروط القانونيه بطبيعه الحال في
نهايه المطاف هو موقف بالنسبه لنا احنا
نواصله العمل وموجوده حتى ضمنت اخرى في
ملاحظات بتاعه مجتمع مدني ومحلي
الانتخابات وسطى مقاطعه من عدد من الاحزاب
والقوه السياسيه الرئيسيه وفي اخر المواقف
جددت حركه النهضه التونسيه دعوتها لمقاطعه
الانتخابات التشريعيه وقالت في بيان لها
انها وضعت على مقاس الانقلاب وبادواته
لتمكينه من الانفراد بالسلطه وتكريس
الاستبداد الفردي وفقا ما جاء في بيان
الحركه ورات ان البرلمان الذي ستسفر عنه
الانتخابات سيكون اقرب الى دعم ما تقرره
سلطه الانقلاب ومن دون صلاحيه او قدره على
اداء دوره الحقيقي في التشريعي والرقابه
حسب ما جاء في بيان الحركه
معنى الان من المركز الاعلامي لهيئه
الانتخابات في تونس مراسلنا سيف الدين
بوعلاج سيف الدين كيف تبدو الاستعدادات
لاقتراع يوم غد
محمد في الحقيقه هيئه
الانتخابات تقول انها جاهزه في لكل ااا
بكل المقاييس واقل المعايير معايير
النزاهه والشفافيه تقول انها عدت العده
لانجاح هذه الانتخابات قانونيا ترتيبيا
وايضا همم اجرائيا
لوجيستيا ايضا في الحقيقه ولكن همم هذه
الانتخابات استثنائيه بامتياز محمد اولا
لانها تجرى بعد اقرار دستور جديد بعد
استفتاء على هذا الدستور وايضا بعد صدور
قانون انتخابي جديد صدر عبر مرسوم رئاسي
في ظل همم الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اقرها الرئيس وخارطه الطريقه التي وضعها
همم وربما المحطه الرئيسيه لخريطه الطريق
هي ال الانتخابات التشريعيه ولكن
الاستثناء ايضا في هذه الانتخابات ونظام
الاقتراع لاول مره حتى ما قبل ثوره
التونسيه كانت الانتخابات تجرى دائما
بمشاركه الاحزاب السياسيه وحتى في نظام بن
علي ربما كان يشبه بالنظام الحزب الواحد
كانت هناك احزاب سياسيه على الاقل الحزب
الحاكم وبعد الاحزاب الاخرى تشارك في هذه
الانتخابات الان الوضع اختلف بشكل جذري
همم الانتخابات او الاقتراع يقوم على
الافراد وليس على القائمات الاختلافات
الحزبيه وذلك ربما ما جعل الحمله كما وصفت
به الضعيفه او همم
طبيعيه في وفي ظروف عاديه كما يقول
المراقبون منظمات المجتمع المدني التونسيه
التي اصدرت بعض
حول هذه المساله همم تحديدا وبالتالي حتى
نتائج الانتخابات لا يمكن التقديم قراءه
او تحليل او همم
اخذ بعض المعطيات منها بالنظر الى ان
الاغلبيه الساحقه من المترشحين لم يعرف
عنهم اي نشاط سياسي او حزبي بعض النشطاء
من المجتمع المدني الذين ترشحوا في هذه
الانتخابات وبالتالي هذا ربما فتح الباب
امام سلسله انتقادات ميناء المعارضه تقول
ان المشاركين او اغلبيه المترشحين هم من
انصار الرئيس قيس سعيد وبالتالي هذا همم
خريطه الطريق
الاصلاحيه همم كما يقول الرئيس سعيد محمد
النقطه الاخيره تتعلق ربما اهم معطى في
هذه الانتخابات ونسبه المشاركه هل ستكون
نسبه المشاركه كما يريدها الرئيس قيس سعيد
لاطفاء شرعيه ومشروعيه على هذه او على هذا
المسار ام ان نسبه المشاركه الضعيفه ربما
قد تؤشر لنجاح لمعارضه التونسيه في
دعواتكم المقاطعه وايضا تاثير الوضع
الاجتماعي والاقتصادي صعب على المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات محمد نعم شكرا لك سيف
الدين بوعلاج من تونس ومن العاصمه
التونسيه كذلك ينضم الينا ابو الباب سالم
الكاتب والمحلل همم السياسي همم سيد سالم
اذا اخذنا تعبير سيف الدين بوعلام ان هذه
الانتخابات استثنائيه يبدو ان استثنائيه
في كثير من انهو من النواحي كيف تبدو قبل
انطلاقها
مساء الخير لك استاذ محمد ولكل المتابعين
قناه الجزيره
كان يشهد كان حدثا دوليا بامتياز ربما
لاول مره
ربما هذا العزوف وهذه الورود وهذه
الاحتشام في
ربما في الاحتفال بهذا الموعد الكبير يعني
الموعد الذي خبات التشريات لاسباب عديده
يعني السبب الاول هو ان همم طبعا هناك
مقاطعه واسعه من الاحزاب الرئيسيه والكبرى
والفاعله في البلاد من جبهه خلاص الوطني
حول طريقه تسير المنطلق الرئيس قيس سعيد
المساله الاخرى كذلك هي الانتخابات على
الافراد يعني لاول مره
كانت انتخابات العراق وليس على القائمات
ونبي ال- اا الذي سله الرئيس قيس سعيد همم
فهميش الاحزاب هنا وبالتالي هناك نعلم
جيدا طبعا
[موسيقى]
الحداثه السياسيه وان التحذبه والاحزاب هي
من تعتبر يعني قمه التنظم السياسي المدني
يعني وقع تهميشها ولم نراها في الحمله
الانتخابيه لا تجمعات انتخابيه حقيقيه ولم
نرى صراع برامج لم نرى كذلك افكار او
تصورات او مشاريع يعني اغلب المترشحين
النكرات يعني ليس لهم اي سيره سياسيه هذا
يعني جعل الحمل كما قلت الانتخابيه بارده
جدا
من غير مقبول مثلا ان الرئيس هو الذي
ستردستور الرئيس هو الذي يسمى القانون
الانتخابي دون اشتراك اي طرف من هذه من
الاطراف يعني
الناشطه في المجتمع المدني او حتى من
الهيئات 307 هو بنفسه مثل هيئه الانتخابات
يعني وقع تجاهلها بالكامل واصدر يعني
قانون انتخابيه المنفريدا على مقاسه يكرس
البناء
المشاركه موضوع نسبه المشاركه اذا اخذنا
نسبه المشاركه في المهجر وقال انها كانت
ضعيفه وربما ضعيفه جدا هل هذا مؤشر لما
يمكن ان يحدث في الداخل
طبعا يعني الارقام الوارده يوم امس حول
نسبه المشاركه في الخارج كانت هزيمه
وهزيله جدا تقريبا من
386,000 يعني
تقريبا
انتخب منهم 110 شخص فقط
لم يزورها اي يعني داخل هناك مكاتب مغلقه
دوائر بدون مرشحين وهذا يحصل لاول مره في
التاريخ
لا يوجد بها مرشحون همم في داخل كذلك طبعا
اعتقد ان نسبه المشاركه ستكون همم ضعيفه
بسببك العام الاول هو المقاطعه الواسعه
على الاحزاب الكبرى يعني الاحزاب هي التي
الماكينه
الحزبيه هي التي تزين الناس وتدفعهم
للمشاركه وتحاول طبعا التاثير في الراي
العام الى غير ذلك هذا لم يحصل في هذه
القضيه
وليس لديهم يعني همم اليات شعبيه حتى
لتاثير على الناخبين وبالتالي يعتقد ان
نسبه المشاركه حتى يوم غد يعني ستكون نسبه
يعني ضعيفه ضعيفه جدا شكرا لك يا ابو سالم
ملك الكاتب والمحل السياسي من تونس
[موسيقى]
استاجن العاهل الاردنيه الملك عبد الله
الثاني الاعتداء على رجال الامن في بلاده
وذلك بعد مقتل نائب الشرطه في محافظه معان
في مواجهات مع محتاجين جنوبيه البلاد وقال
خلال تقديمه واجب العزاء لعشيره الدلابيح
انه لن يهدى لهبال حتى ينال المجرم عقابه
على حد تعبيره وكانت قوات الدرك قد عززت
حضورها بمنطقه الحسينيه عقبه مواجهات
داميه ليله الجمعه بعد اضراب ان استمر
لاسبوعين ضد قرارات الحكومه برفع اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه
عاد الى بلدته محمول على اكتاف رفاق
السلاح الاف الاردنيين شيعوا في الكثير
بمحافظه جرش شمال العاصمه جثمان العقيد
عبد الرزاق الدلابيح نائب مدير شرطه
محافظه معان الذي قضى برصاصه في الراس في
منطقه الحسينيه جنوبا قبيلته منحه الحكومه
ثلاثه ايام لمعرفه قاتل ابنها ورفضت
استقبال اعضاء الحكومه ومجلس الامه
هو القاتل وانه ال- الحكومه الاردنيه غير
ممثل وغير مرحل فيها نتيجه تشارك في هذا
العذاب
والى الجنوب الاردني في الحسينيه التي
كانت مسرحا للاشتباك بين قوات الدرك ومن
سماهم الامن خارجين عن القانون يبحث الامن
عن الادله لمعرفه مطلقين الرصاص تطور يوصف
بالخطير هنا الاحتجاج ضد رفع اسعار
المحروقات عقب اسبوعين على اضراب سائقي
الشاحنات بسبب عدم قدرتهم على تحمل المزيد
من غلاء المشتقات النفطيه
ليله الجمعه كانت دمويه في الحسينيه
وشاهدت غضبا ايضا عبر اغلاق الطرق وحرق
الاطارات في كل من ناعور وما ادبه
والزرقاء والكرك وعجلون ومدن وقورا اردنيه
اخرى
اللي تشهد اعمال العنف وراح يكون فيه
اجراءات غريبه في هذه المناطق
لكن هذه الاجراءات هي فقط موجهه لمن
يستخدم العنف
استعاد الامن وسيطرته على الخط الصحراوي
عبر تعزيز حضوره في المدن القريبه من هذا
الخط وفي هذه المشاهد يرافق الامن حافلات
وسيارات تقل سياحا وجهتهم العقبه كما هو
الحال بالنسبه الى تامين حركه الشاحنه من
والى الميناء الاردني الوحيد في العقبه
توعد الامن بتجديد قبضته لحمايه الارواح
والممتلكات في البلاد فيما وجهت انتقادات
اذاعه للحكومه التي دخلت على خط الازمه
متاخره براي منتقديها ولم تقدم حلولا
حقيقيه لهذه الازمه المفتوحه منذ بدايه
الشهر ذروه الاشتباكات مع التي قضى فيها
العقيد الدلابيح كانت في هذا الشارع قوات
الدرك في كل مكان على امتداد الطريق
الصحراوي والمشهد الامني يهيمن على ما الت
اليه الاحتجاجات على رفع اسعار المحروقات
حسن الشوبك الجزيره الحسينيه جنوبيه
الاردن
[موسيقى]
تشهد حركه النقل والسفر في بريطانيا
اضطرابا متزايدا بعد دخوله مئات من عمال
الخدمات الارضيه في مطاره بالعاصمه لندن
في اضرابا للمطالبه بزياده اجورهم قبل ان
يقوموا بوقف الاضراب في وقت اللاحه في
اثناء استئناف نحو 40 الف من سائقين وعمال
القطارات في عموم البلاد اضرابهم المطالبه
بزياده اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم وتشهد
اجزاء في جنوب وغرب العاصمه اضرابا جزئيا
للسائقه حافلات النقل العام كما تشهد مدن
اخرى في شمال انجلترا اضرابا للعاملين في
اداره الطرق السريعه
معنى من لندن سليمان النقل والسياحه في
صحيفه
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد كولدر كيف الخروج من
دوامه الاضرابات هذه في قطاع النقل بشكل
خاص
صعب
الحديديه قطاع بالغ الاهميه في المملكه
المتحده
لانها دوله صغيره ومقتظه وبالتالي حين
تحصل هذه الاضرابات وهي من الاسوء التي
شاهدناها في اخر اربعين عاما وذلك في
خدامها هذا الشتاء القارس الذي يشهد
الكثير من العرقلات وتعطيلات بسبب الثلوج
والجليد ايضا هذا فعلا يرهق الناس ويرغموا
الناس
طرق ضيقه او اصغر وليس هناك مؤشر الى
نهايه هذه الازمه لدينا ثمانيه ايام
وجدوله من الاضرابات فعلا انا سمعته منذ
قليله انه في السادس والعشرين من شهر
ديسمبر فكافه القطارات الدوليه التي تنقل
الناس من لندن الى باريس وام سردام قد
الغيت وهذا يمثل 20
الفراكب كانوا يحسبون انه يمكنهم ان
يسافروا سفره دوليه واخشى انهم سوف لن
يتمكنوا من السفر انها دوله في ازمه صعبه
الحكومه لحد الان تبدو غير مستعده للتجاوب
مع هؤلاء او الدخول في تفاوض معهم اذا اذا
ما العمل في هذه الحاله
كريستيانو
المحافظه
تعتبروا انها معركه هي قادره على ان تفوز
بها في مواجهه النقابات العماليه
اليساريه هي تعتبر انه يجب ان تترك هذا
الاضرابات تحصل حتى يتعب ويسام ويستسلم
العمال وبالتاليتا قبلنا عدم رفع اجورهم
كما يطالبون او بالمستوى الذي يطالبون به
للاسف فان الملايين من الركاب المسافرين
هم الضاحيه نحن نريد ان نرحب بالناس
السياح والزوار كافه انحاء العالم يصلون
ويشهدون
القطارات غير شغاله ولا يمكن ان ننتقل من
المطار الى المدينه هذا محرج جدا
ربما بعد بعد فتره قصيره في التعامل مع
النقابات
القنوات 20
شاهدنا اضرابات طويله
لعمال المناجم وفي النهايه الحكومه هي
التي فازت وهذا الحكومه همم من الحزمه
المحافظ التي نراها تعتقد ان المسافرين في
المملكه المتحده بداوا يسامون حين يرون
انا خياراتهم في تنقل قد انتهت لدينا
ادراك اخر يبدا غدا لمده اربعه ايام
وتامى الحكومه ان العمال المطربين سوف
يخسرون الدعم الشعبي ولكن خلال هذه الازمه
هذا يكلف
البلاد عشرات الملايين كل يوم وكذلك
شكرا على عيون العالم يبدو اننا بلد عاجز
عن التعامل مع الوضع
محرر شؤون النقل والسياحه في صحيفه
الانفندا
[موسيقى]
اطلقت سلطاته الصحيه اللبنانيه حمله
التلقيح واسعه لمواجهه انتشار الكوليرا
وذلك بعد تجاوز عدد المصابين 5000 اغلبهم
في شمال البلاد وشرقها وعازات منظمه الصحه
العالميه سببا انتشار الكوليرا في جميع
المحافظات اللبنانيه الى عوامل عده ابرزها
قله توفر المياه النظيفه وتردي خدمات
الصرف الصحي وارتدادات الازمه الاقتصاديه
المواجهه الاول في وجهي اي طارئ صحي في
لبنان وقد ان الاوان ليتحسن ضد الكوليرا
في العاملون في مستشفى رفيق الحريري
الحكومي ياخذون معركه مواجهه البكتيريا
فالكوليرا التي عادت الى البلاد بعد عقود
من احتوائها دفعت وزاره الصحه لاطلاق حمله
تلقيح واسعه النطاق في المرحله
الاكثر خطوط للتعرض للوباء نحن خلال 10
ايام راح يصلي 900000 شرعا وراح نبدا
بالمرحله الثانيه بما تبقى من مناطق
انهك المرض مصطفى فالطفل الذي لم يتجاوز
الرابعه بدات رحله علاجه للتوب ومع تدفق
الحالات المشتبه فيها الى هذا المستشفى في
محافظه عكار تواجه المستشفيات الميدانيه
التي انشات بشكل استثنائي تحديات جمه ان
كان المتطوعين الاطباء من التحديات يعني
كنا عاطلين الهم كيف بدنا نكفي ونستمر
عندنا اعداد يعني عندك دقيقتين متطوع
حاليا بالمستشفى بالاضافه للاطباء
يهزئون من وضع فاق قدرتهم على الاحتمال
فكل مقومات الحياه مفقوده هنا فلاجئون
السوريون يؤكدون ان الاصابات بالكوليرا
تنتشر في صفوفهم نتيجه التلوث وغياب البنا
التحتيه عن مخيمتهم
وعلى طول الاولاد على طول عم يلعبوا هون
يعني لا تقتصر تجليات الازمه هنا على مياه
الصرف الصحي بل تصل الى مياه الشرب
والماكل ويعاني عدد كبير من سكان المخيم
عوارض الكوليرا دون ان تجرى لهم فحوص
مخبريه كحالي اطفال خديجه عم نشرب من ميه
البير يعني
هي عم- كل المخيم تقريبا عم يشرب منها
بخوف كثير يعني هلا اولادي ثلاثه كلهم عم
يعانوا من الاسهال ما فيني همم توجه لاي
مركز لانه اكيد التكاليف رح تكون كبيره
وانا ما فيني عليها وعلى الرغم من تعويض
السلطات على قرب احتواء الكوليرا يبقى
المسار طويلا وشقا فالمعضله لا تكمن في
القضاء على الوباء وحسب بل تتعداه الى لي
انعكاسات الصحيه للبنيه التحتيه المتهلكه
بعدم قدره السلطات على اصلاحها تعود
الكوليرا الى لبنان بعد ثلاثه عقود من
احتوائها وعلى الرغم من الجهود المبذوله
لمواجهتها فانها تضع نظام الصحه
والاقتصاديه امام تحديات اضافيه لبلد يشهد
انهيارا غير مسبوق على المستويات كافه
كارمن جوده الجزيره عكار شماليه لبنان
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى موضوع الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه
اليابانيه الجديده التي اعلنت عنها
الحكومه اليوم
تاريخ واليابان العسكريه لفتره زمنيه
تتجاوز
3000 سنه تميز بفتره طويله من حروب
العشائر حتى القرن الثاني عشر ميلادي
تبعتها فتره من الحروب الاقطاعيه التي
بلغت ذروتها في عهد الحكومات العسكريه
التي عرفت
الطبقه العسكريه اليابان منذ عام
1192 وحتى عام
1868 كان محاربوه الساموراي وشغلات على
مقربه من قمه الهرم الاجتماعيه الياباني
تحولت اليابان من الحكم العسكري الى الحكم
الامبرياليه في القرن التاسع عشر عقب
وصولي بعثه الاميرال بيري الى اليابان
وصعود الامبراطور ميسي تاثرت في تلك
الفتره بالقوه الاستعماريه الغربيه
ولمبرياليه الغربيه في اسيا ما ادى الى
تفشل الامب هي اليابانيه والاستعمار
الياباني حتى هزيمه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وفي عام
1947 اعتمدت اليابان دستورا جديدا يحضر
عليها شن الحروب على الدول الاخرى في موضع
هجوم ما ادى الى انشاء قوات الدفاع
الذاتيه اليابانيه المعروفه بلجيكا تايم
في عام
2015 واعيد تفسير الدستور الياباني ليسمح
للبلاد بالدفاع المشترك عن حلفائها وفي
الوقت الحاضر تمتلك اليابان خامسه اقوى
جيشنا في العالم
قرروا طوكيو القيامه بمراجعه الجذريه
لكامل سياستها الدفاعيه تحت عنوان التصدي
للنفوذ العسكريه امر غير مسبوق بالامن
الارخبيل يشمل عده خطوات ستتخذها الحكومه
اليابانيه على مدى سنوات
فهي تخطط مثلا لمضاعفه ميزانيتها الدفاعيه
السنويه لتصبح اثنين بالمائه بحلول 2027
اي حوالي 300 مليار يورو على مدى خمس
سنوات
وتشدد السياسه الجديده على اهميه القدره
علشان هجوم المضاد اذا تسعى الدوله الى
شراء 500 صاروخ ثمود كروس من الولايات
المتحده وايضا صواريخ اف ام سته بعيده
المدى استنادا لما ذكرته وكاله الانباء
اليمنيه
وتريد نشر اكثر من 1000 صاروخ كروز طويل
المدام كما تخطط اليابان لرفع عدد وحدات
قوات الدفاع الذاتي المجهزه بقدرات اعتراض
للصواريخ البالستيه بمقدار ثلاثه اضعاف
تعتزم ايضا طوكيو بناء حولين 130 مستودعا
جديدا للذخيره على اراضيها بحلول 2005 و30
لاستيعاب صواريخ الهجوم مضاد وغيرها من
الاسلحه معنى الان من جناب ليونيل فانو
الاستاذ المساعد للعلاقات الدوليه بجماعه
ويسترن
والباحث بمعهد تاريخ الاسلحه العالميه في
جامعه ميجي اهلا وسهلا بك السيد فتون هل
نحن امام يابان جديده بالكامل
استمرار في تطورين هذه السياسه دفاعيه
والمواقف العسكريه ولكن هذه الوثائق
الثلاثه التي تم مراجعتها اليوم اظهرت ان
اليابان قد تطورت الى درجه صارت لديها
اليوم القدره على تاثير في الديناميكيه
العسكريه في المنطقه من قبل
ذكر ان موقفها كان موقفا دفاعيا حصريا فقط
لحمايه اراضيها والمناطق المجاوره ولكن
الان انها ايضا تريد ان تؤثر على علاقات
اخرى في المنطقه ويمكننا ان نناقش الموضوع
وذلك من خلال اقتناء صواريخ بعيده المدى
اذا بدات اليابان تغير موقفا استراتيجي في
هذه المنطقه طبعا هي تنظر او الص تراقب
همم اليابان وما ستقوم به في الاشهر
المقبله حجم الانفاق العسكري المتوقع كبير
هل هذا يمكن ان يضر باي مكان
اقتصاديه معروفه المكانه الاقتصاديه
المعروفه لليابان
اليابانيه لا تزال تناقش كيفيه تمويل يا
هدى الارتفاع الكبير في الميزانيه لكي
تشكل اثنين في المئه من اشبال الناتج
المحالي 2017
كثيره تدور حاليا ولكن ما يجب ان لا ننسى
هو انا اليابان هي الدوله متطوره طبعا
ولكنها مثقله ديون اكثر من 200% من
اجماليات المحليه
وبالتالي سيكون لديها صعوبه في تمويل هذا
الميزانيه الدفاعيه وستقوم باصدار السندات
الحكوميه
حاليا حاليا لديها ضرائب على الاستهلاك
وعلى الدخل ولكنها متدنيه
واعتقد ان هناك قدره لكي تتمكن من تعزيزي
الميزانيه فديفاعيه ولكنها تسير في مسار
تعزيزي التعاون بين القطاعين العسكري
والخاص
وزياده هذه الميزانيه الدفاعيه قد تاتي
بنناميه جديده الى الاقتصاد الياباني مثل
نصف المحولات مثلا او التجهيزات البصريه
مثلا وهذا طبعا قد يؤثر سيكون عبئا ولكن
اذا اشترى حتى الحلول الملائمه يمكنها ان
تتكبد زياده في الميزانيه الدفاعيه ايضا
جزء كبير من الاسلحه سيكون من الولايات
المتحده هل يخشى نوع من الارتان الياباني
الاقوى من السابق تجاه الولايات المتحده
اريد ان هذا سيحصل فاعتقد ان اليابان هي
تتوجه نحو موقفا دفاعيه اكثر استقلاليه عن
الولايات المتحده طبعا انا لا احسم انها
سوف لن تعود شركه اساسيا في الامن والدفاع
مع الولايات المتحده ولكن لا نرى اليابان
تطور منظومه عسكريه جيشا قادرا على ان
يعمل لوحده
القوات قوات الامن
الدفاعي
المتحده من اجل ان تحمل الولايات المتحده
اليابان بطريقه فعاله الان العكس صحيح هي
لا تكون مرتهنا للولايات المتحده لا اعتقد
ان اليابان
تنقى بنفسها بعد الشيء تحاول ان تستقل
بذاتها اضيفوا انها سوف تستمر في الاعتماد
على الولايات المتحده في جوانب كثيره من
عملياتها الدفاعيه لقد ذكرتهم الصواريخ
البعيده المدى فاحت المشاكل الرئيسيه التي
تواجهها فيها اعتمادها على الاستخبارات
الامريكيه وطبعا من الصعب ان تضرب اي هدف
ان لم تره وعلى او خلال سنوات العقود
المقبله سوف تكون معتمده على المعلومات
التي توفرها لها الولايات المتحده كما
تعلم بحركات الجيش الصيني والكوري الشمالي
[موسيقى]
العلاقات الدوليه بجماعه
يودي الناخبون التونسيون داخل البلاد
اليوم السبت باصواتهم في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وقد اعلنت هيئه الانتخابات في
ردها على الانتقادات قالت انها بمنئه عن
اي تجاربات سياسيه وتدور الانتخابات وسطى
مقاطعه عدد من الاحزاب السياسيه الرئيسيه
منها حركه النهضه التي اعتبرت ان
الانتخابات وضعت على مقاس ما سمته
الانقلاب وبادواته لتمكينه من الانفراد
بالسلطه وتكريس الاستبداد الفردي وفقا ما
جاء في بيان الحركه
علق موقع تويتر حسابات لسته صحفيين يعملون
في وسائل اعلام الامريكيه من بينها سي ان
ان ونيورتايمز واشنطن بوست وقبل القرار
بتمديدا غربي فيما قال المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان الخطوه
تشكل سابقه خطيره وصفت المفوضيه الاوروبيه
الامر بغير المقبول ولوحت بفرد عقوبات
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد دمتم في رعايه
الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]